John built me a Red Room so like for us
like a Red Room is not I don't for me
it's not this crazy uncomfortable thing
I think some people feel guilty and its
pleasures so you know put it together
and that's my guilty pleasure
next Monday it's all about guilty
pleasures on Dancing with the Stars
I read you love a sexy romance novel yes
I do
I I love them et join WWE superstar
Nikki Bella and her pro partner
artemchik Vince said that their dance
rehearsal on Thursday where we learned
Nikki loves romance novels so much her
fiance John Cena built a Red Room a la
Fifty Shades of Grey in their home the
walls are like beautiful red velvet
walls actually the door going into it
looks like a door from a castle it's
it's pretty insane has like for rugs
candles chandelier a lot of drawers can
you play with each other in other rooms
of the house or is it only happen in the
Red Room oh no I mean there's no there's
no rules okay we could go anywhere nikki
is putting all that passion into her
Viennese Waltz she's loving the numbers
so much she may even perform it again
with John at their upcoming wedding it
would be an amazing first would you I do
want to just dance are you gonna do like
a big ballroom dance no yeah right
socially cousin I feel like my guests
are gonna expect it so I'm gonna let him
down if I don't but I mean I'm doing
black-tie and so I think I have to do
some type of waltz I know yeah who's
that here's my coat
[Music]
you